hello there my name is Dennis I work at
dice in Stockholm on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I'm really happy and
excited to be here today so thank you so
much for hanging out with me for a
little bit so we launched our games in
November of last year and clearly we
didn't get it quite right so instead of
coming out of the gate sprinting like we
really wanted to we had to take a step
back and make sure that we were
delivering the game that our players
really wanted so we decided to
completely overhaul our progression
system and add a bunch of new character
cosmetics for players to collect instead
so from there we added a new hunt mode
inspired by the original battlefront
games that I loved personally starting
with the Ewoks on Endor and thank you we
it turned out to be by far the most
popular update of the game and the team
loved building Ewok hunt so as you might
know we're currently in our Han Solo
season with content from the movie
coming next week it's headlined by the
new Planet Kessel's a really dangerous
place and it features the return of one
of our favorite modes extraction so
looking forward a little bit this summer
we will be introducing a new squad
system to the game which will allow you
to team up much easier and play with
your friends we're also adding a new
star fighter mode focused around
dogfighting which our hero ships and
looking ahead a little bit more we will
also be delivering a new large-scale
multiplayer sandbox experience to focus
around capturing command posts and
attacking and taking out capital ships
but that's not all we know that you have
been asking for new heroes villains and
planets from a certain era that features
a very iconic Star Wars conflict so
I'm excited to confirm that Battlefront
2 this year we'll be going deep into the
Clone Wars it's only fitting that we
begin on the planet Geonosis featuring
multiple levels including the largest
level we have ever built for battlefront
so let's talk about the heroes and
villains first let me introduce the most
powerful droid the leader of the most
powerful droid army in the galaxy
General Grievous and yes he will be
going up against my own personal
favorites Jedi Master obi-wan Kenobi
finally making its debut in Battlefront
after all these years so but we're not
done that's not it they will not come
alone joining them is the Dark Lord and
leader of the separatist alliance Count
Dooku as well as someone to bring
balance to the force
Obi Wan's unruly padawan Anakin
Skywalker the team at home is extremely
excited to be building all of these cool
things EA and dice are committed to
battlefront
we had a rough start but I really think
that this game has a bright future thank
you very much for playing the game
providing us with your feedback talking
to us together we will make this as the
greatest game that we can possibly build
there would be no battlefront without
you so thank you may the force be with
you and enjoy the rest of a3 thanks